This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. When Kirk Coles said it and I were promoting a book, the 99% invisible city last year during the middle of the pandemic, over and over, we were asked how we thought the design of cities might change because of COVID. And by that point, lots of shorter term changes were already visible, like street closures to accommodate outdoor dining and other open air activities. That's Kurt. Hey Kurt. Hey Rogan. Also all the plexiglass partitions like they popped up overnight and they're still everywhere in the bay. I was impressed how the shopkeepers could put them up so fast and fix them in, you know, kind of interesting ways. But they do kind of diminish the retail
这是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马斯。去年疫情期间，当柯克·科尔斯和我正在宣传我们的书《99% Invisible City》时，我们一遍又一遍地被问到，我们认为城市设计会因为新冠疫情发生怎样的改变。在那时，许多短期变化已经显而易见，比如为了适应户外用餐和其他露天活动而进行的街道封闭。那是柯特。嘿，柯特。嘿，罗曼。还有那些有机玻璃隔板，它们一夜之间冒了出来，现在在湾区随处可见。店主们能如此迅速地安装并以各种有趣的方式固定它们，这让我印象深刻。但它们确实在某种程度上削弱了零售
experience. Like I have a hard time hearing through or around them Totally especially when talkers on both sides are also wearing masks. Yeah, I need to lip read to understand people most of the time anyway So I don't love the plexiglass that could go away as soon as it's safe But one thing I do want to keep actually is all the way finding cues the stickers on the floor, like guiding people where to stand, to keep socially distant and keep in line. I mean, I don't want the social distancing to stay, but I love adding an information layer onto the floor, you know, keeping people in line because people are terrible and knowing where to stand and be in line
体验。比如，我很难隔着它们或绕过它们听清对方说话。完全同意，尤其是当双方的谈话者都戴着口罩时。是的，反正我大部分时间都需要读唇语才能听懂别人说话。所以我不太喜欢有机玻璃，一旦安全了，它们就应该消失。但实际上，我确实想保留的一件事是所有的寻路标识，比如地板上的贴纸，引导人们站在哪里，以保持社交距离并排队。我的意思是，我不想让社交距离一直存在，但我喜欢在地板上增加一层信息，你知道，让人们排好队，因为人们在知道该站在哪里排队这件事上表现得很糟糕
and just like soothe my anxiety. Yeah, absolutely. And I could see keeping some things like sidewalk seating and car-free streets too. Always assuming that we, you that we vet these for impacts on accessibility and the potential privatization of public space. Of course, that's right.
这确实能缓解我的焦虑。是的，绝对。我也可以预见保留一些东西，比如人行道座位和无车街道。当然，前提是我们必须评估这些措施对无障碍设施的影响，以及公共空间私有化的可能性。当然，没错。
But we're not going to try to predict what designs are going to stick around from our current pandemic. Instead, this week, we're going to look to the past. Kurt and I are going to talk through some of the other designs throughout history that were born out of moments of disaster. And I think some of these examples will really surprise people. Yes, so when you're in the moment, it can be really hard to tell which solutions are just tied to current challenges and which ones are going to stick around.
但我们不会试图预测哪些设计会从当前的疫情中保留下来。相反，本周我们将回顾过去。柯特和我将讨论历史上其他一些源于灾难时刻的设计。我认为其中一些例子会让人感到非常惊讶。是的，所以当你身处其中时，很难分辨哪些解决方案只是针对当前的挑战，而哪些会长期存在。
But we can look to history for some remarkable examples of designs that have persisted, or even evolved further in the wake of a crisis. Okay, let's just start it. Something that surprised me when I was researching this is how truly every day some of these things have become. And one that really grabbed me is this gadget from the early 1800s, which I'm sure looks kind of familiar to you. Yes, indeed. This looks like the precursor to a bicycle. Like, it's not quite a bicycle, but it looks enough like one that I can imagine riding
但我们可以从历史中寻找一些显著的例子，看看哪些设计在危机之后得以保留，甚至进一步演变。好了，让我们开始吧。我在研究这个课题时感到惊讶的一点是，其中一些东西已经变得多么日常。其中一个真正吸引我的是1800年代初的这个小玩意，我相信你看起来会觉得很眼熟。是的，确实。这看起来像是自行车的雏形。它不完全是自行车，但看起来很像，我可以想象骑着它
it like a bicycle. Like, it's not quite there. It's wood, it's metal, it looks a little chunky. It doesn't have pedals. It reminds me of like the scoots that, I don't know if anyone has toddlers, like the little bicycles that basically, that you push along with your feet, like Fred Flintstone. But so what is this thing? It's called the Laufmachina. Laufmachina. Yeah.
就像骑自行车一样。它还差那么一点。它是木制的，金属制的，看起来有点笨重。它没有踏板。它让我想起了那种滑板车，我不知道有没有人有幼儿，就像那种基本上用脚蹬着走的小自行车，像弗雷德·弗林特斯通那样。那么这到底是什么东西呢？它叫“Laufmaschine”。Laufmaschine。是的。
What does that mean? Well, literally translated from German, it means running machine. Oh, okay. And yeah, and as you notice, it's basically one step or, well, technically two pedals shy of being a bicycle. And the main difference between the two is that in this case, users actually had to run along the ground while struggling this thing. And then they had to pick up their feet and glide along on the wheels, you know, sitting on this kind of awkward seat and middle. So it's exactly like a scoot.
那是什么意思？嗯，从德语直译过来，意思是“跑步机”。哦，好吧。正如你所注意到的，它基本上离自行车只差一步，或者说，技术上讲差两个踏板。两者之间的主要区别在于，在这种情况下，用户实际上必须在推着这个东西的同时在地上跑。然后他们必须抬起脚，让轮子滑行，你知道，坐在中间这种尴尬的座位上。所以它完全就像一辆滑板车。
Yeah, basically, yeah. I mean, it looks, it looks totally fun, like a recreational vehicle for, you know, fancy lands and suits. Exactly. And later it came to have that association, but it was actually created during a shockingly dark period of history. Well, you can have to narrow it down for me because it seems like 90% of history is shockingly dark. Fair enough, fair enough. I mean, the big overarching catalyst behind this was a volcano.
是的，基本上是这样。我的意思是，它看起来非常有趣，就像是为那些穿着考究的绅士准备的休闲车。没错。后来它确实有了这种联想，但它实际上是在历史上一个极其黑暗的时期创造出来的。好吧，你得为我缩小一下范围，因为似乎90%的历史都极其黑暗。说得有道理，说得有道理。我的意思是，这背后的主要催化剂是一座火山。
And it wasn't just any volcano. When Mount Tambora erupted in 1815, it was the largest eruption in recorded human history. And so this event itself causes a bunch of deaths. Tens of thousands of people die. And even though it happened between mainland Asia and Australia, the sound of it could be heard over a thousand miles away. Whoa, but that sounds terrifying. Yeah, absolutely. And it didn't stop there. People close by were the ones who suffered initially, but the volcano had these longer term global impacts that lasted way past the eruption.
而且不仅仅是普通的火山。当坦博拉火山在1815年爆发时，它是人类历史上记录到的最大规模的火山爆发。所以这个事件本身导致了大量死亡。成千上万的人丧生。尽管它发生在亚洲大陆和澳大利亚之间，但在一千英里外都能听到它的声音。哇，那听起来太可怕了。是的，绝对。而且它并没有就此停止。附近的人最初受害，但火山产生了长期的全球影响，持续时间远超爆发本身。
And as far away as Europe, 1816 would become known as the year without summer. They were facing this brown and red snow which was colored by the volcanic ash in the atmosphere and it must have looked to people like the end times had finally come. Yeah. I remember last year when the wildfires kicked ash up into the upper atmosphere and it turned the entire Bay Area orange for a day, like it was a dark orange. It was just one of the weirdest days of my life. It felt so ominous and so just crazy making to me that I kind of didn't know what to do with myself all that.
远至欧洲，1816年被称为“无夏之年”。他们面临着棕色和红色的雪，那是大气中火山灰的颜色，对人们来说，这看起来就像世界末日终于来临了。是的。我记得去年野火把灰烬吹到高层大气中，整个湾区有一天变成了橙色，就像深橙色一样。那是我一生中最奇怪的日子之一。它让我感到如此不祥，如此疯狂，以至于我不知道该怎么办。
I had the same reaction and thinking about it, I at least knew what was causing. I had weather forecast and could comprehend what was going on around me. But I'm trying to picture people at this time who didn't know exactly what was causing this sort of apocalyptic event and and on top of not having a firm grasp of the cause they were in the midst of a lot of other stuff. So a picture this right? Europe at the time is still
我有同样的反应，回想起来，我至少知道是什么原因造成的。我有天气预报，能理解周围发生了什么。但我试图想象当时的人们，他们不知道是什么导致了这种类似世界末日的事件，而且除了不清楚原因之外，他们还深陷于许多其他事情之中。所以想象一下，对吧？当时的欧洲仍然
recovering from the devastation of the Napoleonic wars. So things weren't exactly great to begin with. And then along comes this volcanic winter, which devastates the crops. And so food supplies go down, prices go up, there's riding, thefts, violence, and a top of all of that, you've got the resulting malnutrition, which is driving the spread of diseases. So it's this ugly combination of catastrophe,
在从拿破仑战争的破坏中恢复。所以情况本来就不太好。然后又来了这场火山冬天，摧毁了农作物。于是粮食供应减少，价格上涨，出现了抢劫、盗窃、暴力，最重要的是，由此导致的营养不良正在加剧疾病的传播。所以这是灾难的丑陋组合，
kind of perfect storm of bad fortune. So how did those dire conditions lead to this bike? Right, so the Louth machine, you know, more specifically was inspired by a particularly morbid side effect going on amidst all this. So right, we've got food scarcity, which is leading people to, you know, turn in a lot of new directions, including two horses. Oh, like they ate the horses. Yeah, so people were slaughtering horses for meat and for their
某种厄运的完美风暴。那么这些可怕的条件是如何导致这辆自行车的呢？没错，所以“Laufmaschine”，更具体地说，是受到当时发生的一种特别病态的副作用的启发。所以，我们有粮食短缺，这导致人们转向很多新的方向，包括吃马。哦，就像他们吃了马。是的，所以人们为了肉和皮而屠宰马匹，
hide, and you know, it's not like there was an alternative. I mean, even if you'd wanted to keep your horses alive, there wasn't enough food to feed them. And so it's very grim and very much kind of a product of necessity at the time. Yeah. Yeah. So without horses, people still need to get around. And so that's what creates this the loaf machine. Yep. You got it. That's where this this German inventor comes in. His name is Carl Vendriss. And he has this idea for a two-wheeled alternative to riding on the backs of animals. And you know, so he's tinkering around with this thing and he does his first test ride
而且并不是说有其他选择。我的意思是，即使你想让你的马活着，也没有足够的食物喂它们。所以这非常严峻，在当时很大程度上是一种必需品。是的。是的。所以没有马，人们仍然需要出行。这就是创造“Laufmaschine”的原因。没错。你说对了。这就是那位德国发明家登场的地方。他的名字叫卡尔·冯·德莱斯。他想出了一个两轮替代方案，用来代替骑在动物背上。你知道，他一直在摆弄这个东西，他在1817年左右进行了第一次试骑。
right around that time in 1817. And this first wooded iron mouth machine is a hooking thing. It weighs 50 pounds and it takes human power and it could only travel to miles per hour. But on the other hand, at the time, 10 miles per hour was a pretty good pace. Yeah, but it still sounds a bit awkward, like running along rather than battling. And it sounds like it was only really useful for people who live uphill from something they wanted yet to. Yeah, as a kind of day-to-day device, it was pretty unwieldy. And it took a lot of practice
这个最初的木制铁制“Laufmaschine”是个笨重的家伙。它重50磅，靠人力驱动，时速只能达到2英里。但另一方面，在当时，时速10英里已经是一个相当不错的速度了。是的，但它听起来仍然有点尴尬，就像跑着走而不是骑着走。而且听起来它只对那些住在想要去的地方的上坡处的人有用。是的，作为一种日常设备，它相当笨重。而且需要大量的练习
to learn how to stay balanced and not pull off the thing. And then of course, you've got European roads at the time, which are not all flattened smooth. That's a prolly, you know, for running downhill. No, right. Now, we're sliding smooth. And on top of that, you know, as you said, it's like, you can't go downhill both ways. So people are kind of learning the hard way that these proto bicycles are not the safest or the most efficient device.
才能学会如何保持平衡而不从上面掉下来。当然，还有当时的欧洲道路，并不是所有道路都是平坦光滑的。这对于下坡跑来说是个问题。不，没错。现在，我们滑行得很平稳。最重要的是，正如你所说，你不能两头都下坡。所以人们正在以艰难的方式学习，这些原始自行车并不是最安全或最高效的设备。
But you know, for it to, you know, take root and take off, it must have been popular enough to overcome these shortcomings and have people use them. Yeah, that's the thing. It was still popular enough that it quickly spread to England and France. And avid writers of these things would actually wear through their shoes because they spent so much time propelling the machines. They were so popular in some places that municipalities had to ban them for traffic and safety reasons. And amidst all this, they got a new nickname too, the Dandy horse. So this presumably is after the period of time in which the crisis necessitated them. Like, this is when they do become true recreational vehicles.
但你知道，它要扎根并流行起来，一定是因为它足够受欢迎，克服了这些缺点，让人们使用它们。是的，就是这样。它仍然足够受欢迎，以至于迅速传播到英国和法国。这些东西的狂热骑手实际上会磨穿他们的鞋子，因为他们花了太多时间来推动这些机器。它们在某些地方非常受欢迎，以至于市政当局不得不以交通和安全为由禁止它们。在这一切之中，它们也有了一个新的绰号，叫“花花公子马”。所以这大概是在危机迫使它们出现的那段时期之后吧？就像，这是它们真正成为休闲车的时候吗？
Is that, is that right? Yeah, I mean, they start to have these kind of aristocratic associations, like fancy dandy's going around town on their fancy dandy horses. Although the horse party is kind of macaw, right, because it still harkens back to the sort of dark origins of the device. And then ultimately, you know, they grow a bit less popular as such, because they're not super functional. And they start to evolve too. People would trade out the wood for steel. And then, of course, there's this really critical development Which you could probably guess wrong with this
是这样吗？是的，我的意思是，它们开始有了这种贵族联想，就像时髦的花花公子骑着他们时髦的花花公子马在城里转悠。尽管“马”这个词有点令人毛骨悚然，对吧，因为它仍然让人想起这种设备黑暗的起源。最终，你知道，它们作为这种东西的受欢迎程度有所下降，因为它们的功能性不是特别强。它们也开始进化。人们会把木头换成钢。然后，当然，有一个非常关键的发展，你可能猜到了
Pedals of that thing yeah, I got a pizzer pedals of the thing And that's what this French mechanic caught in 1863 when he added a crank and pedals to the front wheel hub and With that one move he essentially created the first true bicycle as we know it. By the end of that century, the bicycle had come full circle, right? It started as this kind of functional solution and become this kind of dangerous hobby horse thing. And then it was back to being this kind of functional mode of transportation. And it came to have other associations too. Like in hindsight, bikes played a really critical role in helping 19th century women gain both physical but also social mobility. I mean, it's just amazing to think of it that it all started with this confluence
踏板。是的，我猜到了踏板。这就是1863年那位法国机械师所做的，他在前轮毂上增加了一个曲柄和踏板，通过这一举动，他基本上创造了我们所知道的第一辆真正的自行车。到那个世纪末，自行车已经走了一个完整的圆圈，对吧？它最初是一种功能性的解决方案，后来变成了那种危险的爱好马。然后它又回到了这种功能性的交通工具。它也产生了其他的联想。比如事后看来，自行车在帮助19世纪女性获得身体和社交流动性方面发挥了非常关键的作用。我的意思是，想到这一切都始于这种汇合，真是太神奇了
of just absolute disasters. I mean, it's not too surprising because like, you know, they always say that, you know, necessity is the mother of invention. But this was a really grim sort of circumstances that led to this thing that I think it's a, you know, pretty unalloyed, delightful good in the world. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, really dark necessity in this case, leading to something that's really widespread today. And, and as I was digging into this story, right, of the bicycle, It got me thinking like, what other things are there like this? Or was this just a one-off loop, right? Are there other everyday designs that we take for granted now that have their roots and tragedy? And that's when I came across the rise of miniature golf during the great depression of all times.
纯粹的灾难。我的意思是，这并不太令人惊讶，因为你知道，人们常说“需求是发明之母”。但这确实是一系列非常严峻的情况，导致了这个我认为在世界上是纯粹、令人愉悦的好东西。是的。是的。我的意思是，在这种情况下，非常黑暗的需求导致了今天非常普遍的东西。而且，当我深入研究这个自行车的故事时，它让我思考，还有什么其他类似的东西吗？还是这只是一个偶然的循环？还有其他我们现在认为理所当然的日常设计，其根源在于悲剧吗？那时我发现了大萧条时期迷你高尔夫的兴起。
That is not an association I would have made. So when I picture miniaturical courses, I kind of think of like the World War II era, I mean, like sort of kitschy leisure and baby boomers and that kind of thing, not the great depression. Yeah, right. I mean, the last thing on your mind, will you look at a mini golf course is the worst economic crash in modern history. So did mini golf come up because like it was too expensive to maintain big fancy golf courses or something like that? I mean, that's part of it, right? There's no way you're going to maintain these huge grounds for just a couple people walking along with their golf clubs and like all
那不是我会建立的联系。所以当我想到迷你高尔夫球场时，我想到的是二战时代，我的意思是，某种媚俗的休闲和婴儿潮一代之类的东西，而不是大萧条。是的，没错。我的意思是，当你看着一个迷你高尔夫球场时，你脑子里最不会想到的就是现代历史上最严重的经济崩溃。所以迷你高尔夫的出现是因为维护大型高尔夫球场太贵了吗？我的意思是，这是其中的一部分，对吧？你不可能为了几个拿着高尔夫球杆走来走去的人而维护这些巨大的场地，以及所有
that we associate with sort of luxurious sprawling golf courses. That was kind of not on the agenda financially, but also there's just the matter of space, right? You've got all these people who are in cities and need something to do. And, you know, they don't have transportation to get out of cities. So many golf becomes this kind of logical solution, kind of in-fill solution in the urban environment. Right. So like along with everything else real estate prices plunged and there's some space and you might, you know, if you have a little bit of space, you can build, you know, a miniature golf course. Yeah, that's exactly it. The conditions were in some ways
我们与那种豪华、广阔的高尔夫球场联系在一起的东西。从经济上讲，这不在议程上，但还有空间的问题，对吧？你有这么多人在城市里，需要找点事做。而且，他们没有交通工具离开城市。所以迷你高尔夫成为了这种逻辑上的解决方案，城市环境中的一种填充式解决方案。没错。所以就像其他所有东西一样，房地产价格暴跌，有一些空间，如果你有一点空间，你就可以建造一个迷你高尔夫球场。是的，就是这样。在1929年之后，条件在某些方面
totally ideal in the wake of 1929 for exactly this kind of activity. And so while technically mini golf actually predates the stock market collapse, The crisis really ramped up interest in it. You have, as you noted, tons of close businesses and vacant lots and all of this is just right for entrepreneurs to take over. Even in places where there's not extra space, people just made space doing convert rooftops into PB golf courses or parking lots, really anything. And so it was
对于这种活动来说是完全理想的。所以虽然从技术上讲，迷你高尔夫实际上早于股市崩盘，但危机确实加剧了人们对它的兴趣。正如你所指出的，你有大量的倒闭企业和空地，所有这些都非常适合企业家接手。即使在没有额外空间的地方，人们也只是创造空间，把屋顶改造成迷你高尔夫球场，或者停车场，真的什么都可以。所以它是
this surprisingly huge fad. And at one point, somebody even called it the madness of the 1930s. Specifically talking about miniature PB golf is the madness in this race. Wow. Absolutely insanity. That is quite the sequel to the Roarain 20s. Yeah. And so you've got these two very different periods in a way, but there's also this parallel where if you think about it, everybody needs recreation and distraction. It doesn't matter if things are going well or they're going horribly. Given the economic situation in the 30s, cheap activities were naturally much more appealing. On the business side, it's also an opportunity, right? Because people
这种令人惊讶的巨大狂热。有一次，有人甚至称之为“1930年代的疯狂”。专门谈论迷你高尔夫是这场竞赛中的疯狂。哇。绝对的疯狂。这真是“咆哮的二十年代”的续集。是的。所以你有两个在某种程度上非常不同的时期，但也有这种平行之处，如果你仔细想想，每个人都需要娱乐和消遣。无论情况是好是坏，这都不重要。考虑到30年代的经济状况，廉价的活动自然更具吸引力。在商业方面，这也是一个机会，对吧？因为人们
could turn their own yards into courses or the interiors of their unused office buildings, basically anybody could try their hand at building a course. And so tons of people did. Wow. I love picturing that. The people just, I wonder, but normally, like, setting up a miniature golf course, like a lemonade stand, you know, like every, every, every where they can. So winded all the things that I think of when it comes to major golf crop up like the, you know, the mechanical windmills or the ramps and, you know, all that sort of stuff when it that happened. So some of the more technologically advanced stuff came later, but a lot of those basic
可以把自己的院子变成球场，或者把未使用的办公楼内部变成球场，基本上任何人都可以尝试建造一个球场。所以很多人都这么做了。哇。我喜欢想象那个画面。人们只是，我不知道，通常情况下，像摆柠檬水摊一样设置一个迷你高尔夫球场，你知道，到处都是。那么我想到迷你高尔夫时想到的所有东西，比如机械风车或坡道，以及所有这些东西，是什么时候发生的？所以一些技术上更先进的东西是后来才出现的，但很多我们在今天的迷你高尔夫球场中仍然看到的那些基本
things that we still see in miniature golf courses today, do date back to this exact era. Things like ramps and bridges and ridges, people just build out of like available dirt or whatever they could find. And at the same time, you have this recent invention of artificial turf, which helps courses hold up, better to foot traffic. So people who could afford it would add that
东西，确实可以追溯到这个确切的时代。像坡道、桥梁和脊线，人们只是用现成的泥土或他们能找到的任何东西建造。与此同时，你有了最近发明的人造草皮，这有助于球场更好地承受人流量。所以负担得起的人会添加它
to make a more robust course. But really the kind of key in all this is all the odds and ants. Course makers could just grab whatever scraps they could find, pipes and stones and just work them into this bigger design. And there was some scrappy entrepreneurialism in picking the sites for these places too. Like some would situate their courses underneath big lit up billboards so that they could operate it without having to pay for the light bulb or the electricity. Oh, I love it. This is so fun to picture.
来建造一个更坚固的球场。但真正关键的是所有的零碎东西。球场制造者可以抓起他们能找到的任何废料，管道和石头，然后把它们融入到这个更大的设计中。在选择这些地方的地点时，也有一些精明的创业精神。比如有些人会把他们的球场安置在巨大的发光广告牌下面，这样他们就可以在不支付灯泡或电费的情况下运营它。哦，我喜欢它。这画面太有趣了。
Like cities filled with miniature golf courses everywhere. I mean, am I getting this right? Is it really like everywhere? Yeah, I mean, I've literally seen pictures of it being everywhere. And like, I love these images of like little rooftops that are who are people are crowded around, like playing mini golf. And you know, it's totally the opposite of what we can imagine today, right? Like you look at New York City and you think, well, every bit of real estate is used and expensive. But back then, it was like, no, there were little spaces you could cram into. And so
就像城市里到处都是迷你高尔夫球场。我的意思是，我理解对了吗？它真的像到处都是吗？是的，我的意思是，我真的见过它到处都是的照片。而且，我喜欢这些小屋顶的照片，人们挤在上面玩迷你高尔夫。你知道，这完全是我们今天无法想象的，对吧？你看纽约市，你会想，每一寸房地产都被利用了，而且很贵。但当时，情况是，不，还有一些你可以挤进去的小空间。所以
people would just head out and droves and go play mini golf. Well, I mean, mini golf is delightful. So it doesn't surprise me all that much, but the ubiquity of it that you're describing really is striking. Yeah. And of course, with all these creators vying to make their course the best course and trying to attract, you know, more players, there was innovation around that too, like ways that people would try to set there's a part.
人们会成群结队地出去玩迷你高尔夫。好吧，我的意思是，迷你高尔夫很令人愉快。所以这并不让我感到太惊讶，但你描述的那种普遍性确实令人震惊。是的。当然，随着所有这些创造者竞相让他们的球场成为最好的球场，并试图吸引更多的玩家，围绕这一点也有创新，比如人们试图让他们的球场脱颖而出的方式。
Things like pools and mases and traps popped up and eventually more kind of fancy things, like fountains and forests and castles, and even replicas of famous architecture, like the Taj Mahal or the Great Wall of China. And so over time, these things become almost like tiny theme parks, right? Like just populated with all kinds of wild and creative and colorful stuff. And this one in particular that I read about, I think, is my personal favorite feature, which is a trained monkey that goes after your ball. So if you're not careful, it'll just come and snatch your ball and it's like game over. I would definitely go to that park. Oh, yeah. Yeah. I wish that one was
像水池、迷宫和陷阱之类的东西冒了出来，最终出现了更花哨的东西，比如喷泉、森林和城堡，甚至还有著名建筑的复制品，比如泰姬陵或中国长城。所以随着时间的推移，这些东西几乎变成了微型主题公园，对吧？就像充满了各种狂野、创意和丰富多彩的东西。我读到的这个特别的球场，我认为是我个人最喜欢的功能，是一只训练有素的猴子，它会去追你的球。所以如果你不小心，它就会过来抢走你的球，就像游戏结束一样。我肯定会去那个公园。哦，是的。是的。我希望那个球场
still around today. But a lot of the elements are still around, right? Like, like those complex courses with the miniature architecture, it's like become a kind of staple and it's still like this thing that we associated with like a fun family night out. Totally. It's just sort of fun to imagine New York City just being carpeted with major golf courses and all things. I kind of love it. Oh, I do too. Yeah, I do too. So these are kind of two delightful things born out of a natural disaster and an economic disaster.
今天还存在。但很多元素仍然存在，对吧？比如那些带有微型建筑的复杂球场，它已经成为了一种主打，而且它仍然是我们与有趣的家庭之夜联系在一起的东西。完全正确。想象一下纽约市被迷你高尔夫球场覆盖，这很有趣。我有点喜欢它。哦，我也喜欢。是的，我也喜欢。所以这些是源于自然灾害和经济灾难的两种令人愉悦的东西。
Yeah, yeah. And so to make things a little darker, I want to pivot to another kind of catastrophe, one that we're all familiar with, no matter when we live, and that's war. And some of the most devastating periods of human history have been, of course, marked by human conflicts. And yet, at the same time, tons of well-known inventions are also created during wartime. Yeah, totally. After that of my head, I would say like, glues and rubber and computing, like all the encryption and stuff that came about because of war.
是的，是的。为了让事情变得更黑暗一点，我想转向另一种灾难，一种我们无论生活在什么时候都很熟悉的灾难，那就是战争。人类历史上一些最具破坏性的时期当然是以人类冲突为标志的。然而，与此同时，大量众所周知的发明也是在战时创造出来的。是的，完全同意。我想到的有胶水、橡胶和计算，比如所有因为战争而产生的加密技术之类的东西。
Was there something in particular that jumped out to you? Yeah, amidst all of those inventions that have become part of our everyday life, is something that's really, really every day that we absolutely take for granted, which is cans. And of course, can openers, they go with them. And these kind of jumped out to me not just because canning was developed during a period of disaster, but also because it kept evolving from one conflict and one war to the next over multiple centuries. But this whole evolutionary process starts with Napoleon. I mean, that makes sense. You have troops on the move. You need to attack Russia.
有什么特别的东西让你印象深刻吗？是的，在所有这些已经成为我们日常生活一部分的发明中，有一些非常非常日常的东西，我们绝对认为理所当然，那就是罐头。当然，还有开罐器，它们是配套的。这些东西让我印象深刻，不仅因为罐头是在灾难时期开发的，还因为它们在几个世纪的时间里从一场冲突到另一场战争不断演变。但整个进化过程始于拿破仑。我的意思是，这说得通。你有军队在行进。你需要进攻俄罗斯。
And of course, the Russians aren't super keen on feeding his armies as their atomic course. And so to solve this issue of his, of his troops on the march, needing food, he ends up offering up a prize in 1795. And it's a cash reward to anybody who can help him develop a better technique for keeping food from spoiling. Wow. It's kind of like an ex-price, but more than on earth. Yeah, the Napoleonic ex-price. And so this Frenchman who eventually gets the money ends up spending over a decade doing research and development. So he can earn the prize. And his process of heating and sealing foods and jars is pretty much the same thing that
当然，俄罗斯人并不热衷于喂养他的军队。所以为了解决他行军中的部队需要食物的问题，他在1795年设立了一个奖项。这是一个给任何能帮助他开发出更好的防止食物变质技术的人的现金奖励。哇。这有点像X奖，但更接地气。是的，拿破仑式的X奖。所以这个最终拿到钱的法国人花了十多年时间进行研发。这样他才能赢得奖项。他加热和密封罐子里食物的过程，和
a lot of people still use today. But that's not really canning at this point. Like it's just more like jarring like that. Yeah, right. Yeah. Yeah, right. Yeah. Right, right. So he's using glass jars, but cans were the next big step. And suddenly industrial canaries start to spin up.
很多人今天仍然使用的东西几乎是一样的。但那在当时并不是真正的罐头。就像是装罐子。是的，没错。是的，没错。是的，没错。所以他用的是玻璃罐，但罐头是下一个大步骤。突然间，工业罐头厂开始兴起。
And the cans of the 19th century, for the most part, look, a lot like the ones we see today that got those side ridges that helped strengthen them and allow them to expand and contract. Yeah. Like if you picked up a can off the shelf of a supermarket and took off the paper label, you would see those ridges. Yeah. The basics of the design were there, essentially, from the start. The biggest difference was a complete lack of can open. So you've got these cans. and at the time, they're especially thick and robust, and people had to use hammers and chisels to get them open up until basically the mid-1800s.
19世纪的罐头，在很大程度上看起来很像我们今天看到的那些有侧面脊线的罐头，这有助于加强它们，并允许它们膨胀和收缩。是的。如果你从超市货架上拿起一个罐头，撕掉纸标签，你就会看到那些脊线。是的，设计的核心基本上从一开始就在那里了。最大的区别是完全没有开罐器。所以你有这些罐头，在当时，它们特别厚实，人们不得不使用锤子和凿子来打开它们，直到19世纪中期。
It's really stunning to think about that you could have cans without can openers that they weren't invented alongside of each other. Yeah, it seems crazy, right, that you could have decades between the invention of the can and the invention of the device that opened it. And when it was finally invented, it still wasn't really popular in a kind of general public consumer sense. But during the Civil War, armies were really quick to pick up on this thing and say, wow, yeah, canned goods in the field with devices to open them.
想到罐头没有开罐器，它们不是同时被发明的，真是令人震惊。是的，这看起来很疯狂，对吧，罐头的发明和打开它的设备的发明之间竟然隔了几十年。当它最终被发明出来时，它在普通大众消费者意义上仍然不是很受欢迎。但在内战期间，军队很快就接受了这个东西，说，哇，是的，野外有罐头食品，还有打开它们的设备。
I mean, that's great. Like, that's just what we need. That sounds like quite a breakthrough. Like, is there a reason why ordinary people didn't use them? Is it just like not user-friendly, just expensive? Yes. So, despite the fact that it took so long to invent a can opener, that sort of worked, it was still not the user-friendly can opener.
我的意思是，那太棒了。就像，那正是我们所需要的。这听起来像是一个巨大的突破。普通人没有使用它们有什么原因吗？是因为它不方便使用，还是太贵了？是的。尽管发明一个能用的开罐器花了这么长时间，但它仍然不是那种用户友好的开罐器。
You're probably picturing and that you probably have in your kitchen drawer. People really had to just kind of stab the can and then saw along the edge manually. So as you can imagine outside the military, there wasn't a ton of interest. And where they were used a lot was in grocery stores. But instead of sending you home with a can, the grocery store clerks would actually open the cans for you and send you home with the open cans. So cans weren't for storing stuff at home. It was for storing stuff on shelves of the general store. So yeah, that sort of defeats the purpose of the look handy can that you get at a grocery
你可能正在想象的，你厨房抽屉里可能有的那种。人们真的不得不只是刺穿罐头，然后手动沿着边缘锯开。所以你可以想象，在军队之外，并没有太大的兴趣。它们被大量使用的地方是杂货店。但杂货店职员不是让你带着罐头回家，而是实际上为你打开罐头，让你带着打开的罐头回家。所以罐头不是为了在家里储存东西。它是为了在杂货店的货架上储存东西。所以是的，这在某种程度上违背了你在杂货店买到的那种方便罐头的目的，但我能看出它是怎么运作的。
store, but I can kind of see how it works. Yeah, I mean, it kind of works, but it's totally backward from the way that we think about cancer. Today is like something you can take home for convenience purposes. So zooming out, big picture, there's this back and forth, right, between military and civilian uses in the 1800s. So canning would ramp up for a war, and then that production capacity, like they'd try to figure out a way to put it on shelves and sell it to consumers, even if it meant opening the can and sending you a home
是的，我的意思是，它在某种程度上是有效的，但这与我们今天对罐头的看法完全相反。今天，它就像你可以为了方便而带回家的东西。所以放眼全局，在1800年代，军事和民用用途之间存在这种来回。所以罐头会因为战争而增加产量，然后那种生产能力，他们会试图想办法把它放在货架上卖给消费者，即使这意味着打开罐头并让你带着罐头回家。
with a can. But then in World War One, canned food took its next really big leap forward. And it happened in part because soldiers really, for the most part, hated it. Heated what? Like, eating canned food? Yeah, they did. They were not big fans of the canned food. And I mean, you can imagine, right? Like it gets old pretty fast, eating canned food in the trenches. And to make things worse, at the time,
但在第一次世界大战中，罐头食品迈出了下一个真正的大飞跃。这在一定程度上是因为士兵们在很大程度上讨厌它。讨厌什么？讨厌吃罐头食品？是的，他们讨厌。他们不太喜欢罐头食品。我的意思是，你可以想象，对吧，在战壕里吃罐头食品很快就会让人厌烦。更糟糕的是，在当时，
there wasn't a lot of selection. And so you can imagine being a British soldier and just eating a lot of pork and peas. And, but during the war, things started to change. And we started to get some variety in canned foods, things like soups and pasta, stuff that we pretty much would recognize today. And so because of this greater diversity in options,
选择并不多。所以你可以想象作为一个英国士兵，只是吃大量的猪肉和豌豆。但是战争期间，情况开始改变。我们开始在罐头食品中获得一些多样性，比如汤和意大利面，我们今天基本能认出来的东西。所以因为这些选择的多样性，
suddenly it was a little bit more appealing to civilians to after the war. So like now that they have good food inside of the cans, you can sell people can opener so they will open them. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, that's, and that's the thing, right? That's the thing we see opened over again.
突然间，战后平民对它更有吸引力了。所以现在罐头里有好吃的食物了，你可以卖给人们开罐器，这样他们就会打开它们。是的。是的。我的意思是，这就是重点，对吧？这就是我们一次又一次看到的东西。
It's like each war, the canning gets a little better or the food gets a little better. And so you have these new innovations and it starts with jars and it goes to cans and then there's better openers and taste your ingredients. And along the way, there are also of course, you know, some tins with built-in openers to make things easier. There's that two-wheeled opener that we still use today, but it wasn't until World War 2 that my personal favorite can opener hit the scene. You have a favorite can opener. Oh, come on. Doesn't everybody have a favorite can opener, uh, hit the, you have a favorite can opener. Oh, come on, doesn't everybody have a favorite can opener? Um, no, but seriously, this thing is all kinds of amazing. Uh, it's
就像每一场战争，罐头变得更好一点，或者食物变得更好一点。所以你有这些新的创新，它始于罐子，然后变成了罐头，然后有了更好的开罐器和更美味的成分。一路上，当然也有一些带有内置开罐器的锡罐，让事情变得更容易。有那种我们今天仍然使用的两轮开罐器，但直到第二次世界大战，我个人最喜欢的开罐器才出现。你有一个最喜欢的开罐器。哦，得了吧。难道不是每个人都有一个最喜欢的开罐器吗？你有一个最喜欢的开罐器。哦，得了吧，难道不是每个人都有一个最喜欢的开罐器吗？嗯，不，但说真的，这个东西非常神奇。它是
called the P 38 and it's not just a can opener. It's this crazy compact little multi tool. It's got this thin middle handle and the blade folds into it. So it packs flat and it can open cans, but it could do all kinds of other stuff. Like what? Well, I'm glad you asked because it can be used as a screwdriver, a bottle opener, a fish gutter, a wire stripper, a flint striker, a letter opener, a coffee stir, a toothpick, a boot scraper, and I mean, that's just the beginning of the list. It's so good. And this is a really good can opener to, I guess.
叫P-38，它不仅仅是一个开罐器。它是一个疯狂紧凑的小型多功能工具。它有一个薄薄的金属手柄，刀片折叠在里面。所以它包装平整，可以打开罐头，但它还可以做各种其他事情。比如什么？嗯，我很高兴你问了，因为它可以用作螺丝刀、开瓶器、鱼肠器、剥线钳、打火石、拆信刀、咖啡搅拌棒、牙签、靴子刮刀，我的意思是，这只是清单的开始。它太棒了。我想这也是一个非常好的开罐器。
Yeah, it's absolutely great. And it's tiny. And it's the best. And so that was in some ways, I mean, to be at least the kind of peak of canning, right? Is World War Two, you've got better canned foods, a better ways to open them. And then we're kind of on the backside of that peak
是的，它绝对很棒。而且它很小。它是最好的。所以这在某种程度上，我的意思是，至少是罐头业的巅峰，对吧？是第二次世界大战，你有更好的罐头食品，更好的打开方式。然后我们处于那个巅峰的背面
following World War II, because suddenly you have refrigerators that are becoming more and more widespread. And so cans suddenly are not really as essential for storing all kinds of food. And for people who are still buying cans, there are these new fangled contraptions, these electric can opener,
第二次世界大战之后，因为突然间你有了冰箱，它们变得越来越普遍。所以罐头突然不再是储存各种食物的必需品了。对于那些仍然在买罐头的人来说，有这些新奇的装置，电动开罐器，
which you start to see popping up in kind of mid-century homes, right? Right. But that push and pull dynamic of like canned foods during a crisis is still present because in the beginning, the pandemic, I bought more canned food than I ever bought in probably the last decade. Oh, yeah. Yeah. For sure. I mean, that's the thing, like the ingrained nature of the can is that it has become functionally associated with disaster. Right? So it may not be a military disaster, but, you know, everybody from like survivalists who are trying to live off the grid to people who are just facing hurricanes or pandemics,
你开始看到它们出现在世纪中叶的家庭中，对吧？没错。但那种在危机期间罐头食品的推拉动态仍然存在，因为在疫情开始时，我买的罐头食品比我过去十年买的都要多。哦，是的。是的。当然。我的意思是，这就是重点，罐头的根深蒂固的本质在于它在功能上已经与灾难联系在一起了。没错。所以它可能不是军事灾难，但是，你知道，从试图脱离电网生活的生存主义者，到只是面临飓风或流行病的人，
like we all have this urge to stockpile cans in case of unexpected or expected disasters. It still serves its purpose pretty well, as long as you can get into them. Yeah, well, I mean, these days they have those little pull tab ones. I mean, those are good. No, it's super easy. Cool. Yeah. So we have one more piece of disaster design innovation after this. So, Kurt's back to talk with me about one more design, something that's far, far older
我们都有这种冲动，囤积罐头以防意外或预期的灾难。只要你能打开它们，它仍然能很好地发挥作用。是的，我的意思是，这些天他们有那些小拉环的。我的意思是，那些很好。不，超级简单。酷。是的。在这之后，我们还有一个关于灾难设计创新的片段。所以，柯特回来和我谈论另一个设计，一个比自行车和迷你高尔夫甚至罐头食品古老得多的东西，但与我们讨论过的其他发展不同，这种特定的设计策略消失了，但最近在新冠疫情期间又回来了。
than bicycles and miniature golf or even canned goods, but unlike those other developments that we've discussed, this particular design strategy went away, but then came back again very recently during COVID. Yeah, it was one of those things where, you know, we're in the midst of this pandemic, and we're seeing a lot of these really new design strategies and technologies and improvements on older strategies, like face masks, which have been around for a long time. But there's this one design that really struck me
是的，这是那种情况之一，你知道，我们正处于这场大流行之中，我们看到了很多这些非常新的设计策略、技术和对旧策略的改进，比如口罩，它们已经存在很长时间了。但有一个设计真正打动了我，
because it had largely gone away for a long time and then it resurfaced last year. And it's called a wine window. I know you got forwarded this like a hundred times. I got forwarded this a hundred times, but it's for people who can't picture it. What is a wine window and what is it for? What does it do? Right. So basically it's a small portal in a wall at sort of like waste to chest height. And it maybe is arched and framed in stone. It's like a tiny fancy little door, but it's much smaller, like a little window. And these were actually designed so customers could buy wine without having to enter a wine shop, which of course is ideal for a period when people are concerned about social
因为它在很长一段时间内基本上消失了，然后去年又重新浮出水面。它被称为“葡萄酒之窗”。我知道你被转发了这个一百次。我被转发了一百次，但对于那些无法想象它的人来说，什么是葡萄酒之窗，它是用来做什么的？它有什么作用？没错。所以基本上它是一个墙上的小入口，大约在腰部到胸部的高度。它可能是拱形的，用石头框起来。它就像一个小巧精致的小门，但它小得多，就像一个小窗户。这些实际上是为顾客设计的，这样他们就可以在不进入葡萄酒商店的情况下购买葡萄酒，这对于人们担心社交距离的时期当然是理想的。
distance. Yeah, it's like a fast food window for the plague. Yeah, fast food window, but for wine and for pedestrians instead of cars, but really the same principle. And so rather than, you know, pulling over and shouting in order into a speaker for a hamburger, you could just throw up and find one of these long, the cobblestone square of an adorable old section of warrants. I love it. I love it. And not just for wine. I just like the idea of walking up and ordering something to a little window in a picturesque old city, although the city wasn't quite as old then. But tell me, were these little walk-up windows created because of pandemics and just
是的，这就像瘟疫时期的快餐窗口。是的，快餐窗口，但它是为葡萄酒和行人而不是汽车准备的，但原则是一样的。所以与其靠边停车并对着扬声器大喊汉堡订单，你只需走过去，在古老而可爱的沃伦区鹅卵石广场上找到这些窗户之一。我喜欢它。我喜欢它。而且不仅仅是为了葡萄酒。我只是喜欢走过去，在一个风景如画的古老城市里向一个小窗户点东西的想法，尽管那个城市当时并没有那么古老。但告诉我，这些小步行窗口是因为流行病而创造的，并且因为在城市中传播的疾病浪潮而得到加强吗？
sort of like reinforced because of the waves of diseases that would come through cities? and just sort of like reinforce because of the waves of diseases that would come through cities? Well, it's a little bit of that and it's a little bit of just like tax history, but basically like in the 1500s, forms changed its wine-vending rules, which allowed people to sell out of their homes. And that led to the very first wine windows. And so yeah, it's tied up in land use and all this kind of bureaucratic stuff. But as time went on, these openings had obviously huge health advantages when the black death, for example, swept across Europe. And so the windows really work. I mean, do they, you know, keep buyers and sellers from passing diseases and dying?
并且因为在城市中传播的疾病浪潮而得到加强吗？嗯，有一点那种原因，也有一点税收历史的原因，但基本上在1500年代，佛罗伦萨改变了它的葡萄酒销售规则，允许人们在家里销售。这导致了第一批葡萄酒之窗的出现。所以是的，它与土地使用和所有这些官僚事务有关。但随着时间的推移，当黑死病在欧洲蔓延时，这些开口显然具有巨大的健康优势。所以这些窗户确实有效。我的意思是，它们（你知道）阻止了买家和卖家传播疾病并死亡吗？
I mean, it certainly seems that way. Like vendors had tried other strategies to cut down on the spread of the Bonic plague, things like soaking coins in vinegar, but line windows helped too. And then slowly over the centuries, a lot of these portals got shut, or were filled in or boreded up, as diseases were held a bit more in check. And then, of course, COVID hit. And because they're still there in some form, right? Like built into the walls, reopening them was a pretty obvious choice.
我的意思是，这看起来确实如此。就像商贩们曾尝试过其他策略来减少黑死病的传播，比如用醋浸泡硬币，但酒窗也起到了一定作用。后来，随着疾病得到了一定程度的控制，几个世纪以来，许多这样的窗口被关闭、填平或封死。然后，当然，新冠疫情爆发了。因为它们以某种形式依然存在，对吧？就像嵌入在墙里一样，重新开放它们是一个显而易见的选择。
It is so interesting, although I mean, it doesn't quite have the same sort of like thing as the miniature golf and bicycle where they, you know, they kind of like persist and evolve. These really just stayed frozen in time. And we're just there to be unborted and opened up when we needed them again. Yeah, I kind of like that difference. I appreciate the fact that they sort of went dormant and then they were exhumed for this purpose that they served so long ago. But yeah, they're definitely not everyday designs, but I kind of want them to be everyday designs, right, I want this to be something that survives this era. And hopefully remains part of the built environment. And even if they do close them, at the very least,
这太有趣了，虽然我的意思是，它不像迷你高尔夫和自行车那样，你知道，它们以某种方式持续存在并不断演变。这些窗口真的只是被冻结在时间里。当我们再次需要它们时，它们就在那里，等着被拆除封板并重新打开。是的，我有点喜欢这种差异。我很欣赏它们进入休眠状态，然后为了它们很久以前所服务的功能而被重新挖掘出来。但确实，它们绝对不是日常设计，但我希望它们能成为日常设计，对吧？我希望这能成为在这个时代幸存下来的东西，并希望它能继续成为建筑环境的一部分。即使它们最终被关闭，至少，
I'd love to see like little plaques show up next to them, saying, you know, these were used historically and once again, during this pandemic. And then maybe who knows, like a couple hundred years from now, when there really is a call to use them again, just reopen them again, right? Yeah, well, I hope there's never a need for future use in the same way that they were used before.
我很乐意看到它们旁边出现小牌匾，写着，你知道，这些窗口在历史上曾被使用过，在这次大流行期间又被再次使用。然后谁知道呢，也许几百年后，当真的有再次使用它们的呼声时，只需再次打开它们，对吧？是的，我希望永远不需要像以前那样再次使用它们。
I mean, one of the great things about the story is that they didn't have to evolve or be used because there was a lot of other technological development in terms of hygiene and health and vaccines that made it so that you didn't need little windows to pass wine. Yeah, and the way their golden arrow was that period in which they weren't used, right, when they were just remnants of a darker time in it.
我的意思是，这个故事最棒的地方在于，它们不需要进化或被使用，因为在卫生、健康和疫苗方面有许多其他的技术发展，使得你不再需要小窗口来传递葡萄酒。是的，它们最辉煌的时期就是它们没有被使用的那段时期，对吧？当它们只是那个黑暗时代的遗迹时。
Yeah, you know, the greatest way that we could use them, you know, in the future, it's just that's quite little inachronisms more than something out in the Sesame. Yes, with little plaques. With little plaques, of course, little plaques. This wasques, of course. Little plaques. This was so much fun. Thank you, Kurt. Yeah, Roman, anytime. 99% of his book was produced this week by our digital director,
是的，你知道，未来我们使用它们的最好方式，就是让它们成为小小的时代错误，而不是某种必需品。是的，配上小牌匾。当然，配上小牌匾。小牌匾。这太有趣了。谢谢你，库尔特。是的，罗曼，随时欢迎。本周的《99%无形》由我们的数字总监制作，
Kurt Colstad. Music, mix, and tech production by our director of Sound, Sean Riel. The Lightning Hall is the executive producer, the rest of the team includes Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Leigh, Chris Baroubaix, Christopher Johnson, Joe Rosenberg, Lashemadon, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are a part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM Podcast family. Now, headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building, in beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California.
库尔特·科尔斯塔德。音乐、混音和技术制作由我们的声音总监肖恩·里尔负责。莱特宁·霍尔是执行制片人，团队其他成员包括埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、薇薇安·李、克里斯·巴鲁贝、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、乔·罗森伯格、拉舍马顿、索菲亚·克拉茨克和我，罗曼·马尔斯。我们是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分。现在，我们的总部位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心以北六个街区的潘多拉大厦。
You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars on the show at 99PI org, or on Instagram and Reddit too. You can find other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI. Dot work.
你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIorg，或者在Instagram和Reddit上关注我们。你可以在99PI.org找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目，以及《99%无形》的所有往期节目。
episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《99%无形》的往期节目请访问99PI.org。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。